[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Обава,
Закарпаття]
Ложки, лопатки. Так із дерева
тільки це вміємо робити і все.
[Олена Волошина
Ложкарка]
Бо ми найбільше робили так...
Одне одного вчили.
[Анатолій Волошин
Ложкар]
Наприклад, я це вмію робити,
і вже моя мала буде робити це.
Я її навчу і на базар ходити, і ложки робити.
Усі ложки йдуть по розміру: є маленькі,
більші, середні, є ще більші.
Залежно від сезону.
Влітку є сезон — то трішки більші йдуть,
бо на варення.
А взимку — слабо, взагалі торгівлі немає.
Влітку — так, і варення, і аджику варять.
І на все — ложка.
[Порошково,
Закарпаття]
Ромське поселення ось там
починається — в кінці тієї ділянки.
А тут скрізь живуть наші (волохи).
[Василь Горбат
Столяр]
У нас народ такий, дружний.
Багато, бачите, дітей дуже.
Тут у мене продуктовий магазин.
Наші, тобто волохи, школу
мають загальну із українцями.
Не мають вони там румунської.
[Жанна Горбат
Мешканка Порошкова]
Наприклад, я вчилася 11 класів в
загальноосвітній українській школі.
Батькові було шістдесят, дідові — 80 років.
Та вже багато років ми тут.
Дуже багато нашої національності.
Було взагалі дві–три хати, а нас тепер 170!
Дітей багато, то у нас у всіх сім'ї.
Ми називаємося волохами,
а традиції маємо і живемо як українці.
Я громадянка України, ми не відрізняємося нічим.
Хочемо працювати як українці і мати своє.
Ну нічим не відрізняємося!
Як обстали нас українці і румуни,
так нас і називають румунами.
— Просто ми не знаємо, де жили раніше.
— Волохи!
[чоловік за кадром] Є, є, вже достатньо їх.
Але вже і румунами ми були,
і бозна-ким ми були.
Люди вже вирішили, що ми
за національністю волохи.
[розмовляють діалектом румунської]
От у мене такий цех.
Тут усі станки заводські.
Я без них жити не можу.
Скоріше буду без жінки, аніж без станків.
Це чесно, не просто сказано для приколу.
Чесно вам кажу, від душі.
12 років мені було, коли я почав з батьком
працювати, і досі я без них не можу.
[розмовляють діалектом румунської]
Стій, Стій! Ага!
Нещодавно мене обрали бароном.
Став спадкоємцем від батька.
А поселення дуже велике.
Це мій брат двоюрідний.
Я його взяв заступником,
бо так легше працювати.
Якщо в когось є проблема —
усіх посилають до барона.
Для барона всі двері відкриті —
в районі, в області.
А для простої людини так не буде.
Я сідаю перша!
Все, їдемо!
Зробили стіл і лавку, веземо їх.
І хочемо встановити на краю села.
Щоби мали місце, де присісти, посидіти.
Контролюємо порядок!
А ми в середу пішли,
то там не було де присісти.
То ми із Сергієм вирішили лавочку і стіл зробити,
щоб було де присісти.
[розмовляють діалектом румунської]
[Чоп,
Закарпаття]
Беріть ложки, ложки!
Купуйте одну ложечку, ложечку!
Беріть ложечки дешеві!
Красулі-ложечки дешеві, ложки!
Купуйте, хоч одну ложечку беріть!
Одну ложку файну!
— Давайте тут.
— Віталік, не знаю. Самі вирішуйте.
— Ось тут.
— Десь ось тут.
[розмовляють діалектом румунської]
Віталік, на рівніше місце став.
— Ну тепер уже можна присісти!
— Звісно!
Зараз у нас збереглась така традиція,
що діти батьків своїх ніколи не кидають.
Тобто, щоб іти десь в інших селах
чи за кордоном жити — то ні.
Зберігають усіх дітей біля себе і не відпускають.
Ложки і довгі, і короткі, і довгі!
Сто гривень! По 30 гривень одна.
— Будете мати решту?
— Йой, ластівко, не маю, може поміняємо десь?
Нема в чоловіка грошей.
Беріть, йдіть поміняйте, бо ви ж перший покупець!
Та тут поміняємо хоч-де в магазині.
У вас є двісті гривень розміняти?
Давайте я...
Ану, в Стьопи не буде поміняти?
Будьте добрі, дівчинці поміняйте.
Немає від ранку ще, перший покупець,
не хочу, аби йшла.
– Та де перший?
– Перший, бо ще ніхто не брав.
Нє, перша, ааай!
Дякую, Господи Боже, поможи
усім людям та й мені!
Беріть одну ложку, одненьку ложечку!
Ложки, ложки, ложки!
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Макс Салій (Завалля), Сергій Розов]
[Субтитрувальниця
Вікторія Перейма]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[USAID
Серія створена за підтримки Агентства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]